she's fought for so long but today
Teresa may finally surrendered ever
since I first stepped through the door
behind me as Prime Minister I have
striven to make the United Kingdom a
country that works not just for a
privileged few but for everyone and to
honor the result of the EU referendum
back in 2016 we gave the British people
a choice against all predictions the
British people voted to leave the
European Union I feel as certain today
as I did three years ago that in a
democracy if you give people a choice
you have a duty to implement what they
decide I have done my best to do that
but in the end her best wasn't good
enough it is now clear to me that is it
it is in the best interests of the
country for a new Prime Minister to lead
that effort so I am today announcing
that I will resign as leader of the
conservative and unionist party on
Friday the 7th of June her husband
watched honours his wife tried to hold
it together but it was all too much I
will shortly leave the job that it has
been the honor of my life to hold the
second female prime minister but
certainly not the last I do so with no
ill-will but with enormous and enduring
gratitude to have had the opportunity to
serve the country I love
this is a decision that we have expected
for weeks if not months but still it's a
catch your breath moment mrs. May says
she tried her best but in the end she
ultimately failed it's the end of May
and the search for a new prime minister
begins as the media circus dissected
what they just seen this political
friend and loyalists admitted to me it
was a difficult watch it was it was
tough it's really tough because you know
it is that that that sense of well yeah
just that sense of pride in her country
pride in our country now that that sense
of what we can be that sense of optimism
that she spoke about and yet sadness
that it's come at a big price for her
and not being able to follow through on
the agenda that I I know she cares about
so much for others the mourning period
will be short the leadership election
officially begins in June but for many
it started weeks ago Boris Johnson at a
conference in Switzerland today teeing
up his big launch the current foreign
Sochi was the first cabinet minister to
break cover today and say he was running
but look at this gaggle of his cabinet
colleagues pretty much all of them are
planning to run to whoever comes out on
top will have to win over the woman
who's propping up two resumes government
we will listen very carefully to what
each of the contenders have to say about
brexit in particular from our
perspective in and around the brexit the
br-2 and the backstop the Tory party
planned to pick a new leader and prime
minister by late July labor think the
people should decide her strategy has
not worked the divisions in the Tory
Party make a conservative government
untenable there has to be an election so
that people can decide their choice for
their future of this country not just on
relations with Europe but at all the
other issues
but it wasn't the public that did for
mrs. Mae it was her party another
conservative prime minister destroyed by
Europe this man knows only too well how
that feels obviously it is a very big
moment a very sad moment because she
cared passionately about the job and
about the country and she wanted to
serve the public just as I did and when
you come to that moment you know your
time is up it's it's extremely hard to
take indeed it is a political career
defined by not showing emotion a
premiership built on a promise to
deliver brexit ending in failure and in
tears bathra be Sky News Westminster